et avec nous pour ce club il sera
bonjour merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
directeur adjoint de la rédaction du
Figaro Erwan l'ESTRO bonjour Erwan merci
d'être la directeur conseil à l'institut
de sondage au doxa Alex nous a rejoint
et Erwan justement va parler de votre
baromètre mensuel au docksa pour Public
Sénat et la presse régionale sur la
réforme des retraites et ses
conséquences sur le quinquennat
d'Emmanuel Macron dont la popularité
chute on verra tout ça et on verra si
les Français pensent qu'il va pouvoir
continuer à réformer se tient
aujourd'hui la dixième journée de
mobilisation contre la réforme des
retraites Gérald Darmanin a déployé un
dispositif de sécurité inédit plus de
13000 policiers et gendarmes à travers
tout le territoire alors faut-il
craindre d'une journée de violence vous
nous direz ce que vous en pensez d'abord
on regarde l'actualité dans nos régions
on va voir comment se prépare la
mobilisation
[Musique]
et l'actualité dans nos régions c'est
cette dixième journée de mobilisation on
va voir comment ça se prépare du côté de
Saint-Étienne on retrouve Anthony
verpillon bonjour Anthony merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous journaliste à TL7 la
télévision locale de la loi Anthony
est-ce qu'il faut s'attendre à une forte
mobilisation du côté de chez vous
en tout cas c'est sûr que depuis deux
semaines maintenant et l'adoption de la
réforme des retraites en tout cas le
recours au 49-3
février
on va on va essayer on va essayer de
rétablir la connexion on vous entend pas
très bien on va essayer de rétablir la
connexion du côté de Saint-Étienne et on
vous retrouve très très vite dixième
journée de mobilisation Yves 13000
policiers gendarmes déployés par Gérald
Darmanin c'est un dispositif de sécurité
inédit est-ce que ça veut dire que le
gouvernement Satan une journée de
violence est-ce que ces journées de
mobilisation qui se sont bien passées
jusqu'à la huitième sont en train de
dériver
oui apparemment mais enfin faut pas
crier avant d'avoir mal vous voyez on va
pas dire faut déjà que les exactions les
violences se produisent donc faut pas
anticiper de façon pessimiste je dirais
mais c'est vrai que il y a eu une dérive
à partir du moment où l'usage du 49-3
était a été révélé
ça a changé un peu la donne mais je
crois que c'est un faux prétexte en fait
parce que on a dit avec le 49-3 c'est
les jeunes sont davantage rentrés dans
le mouvement ils ont contesté la forme
et la procédure employée par le
gouvernement certes mais je crois
qu'au-delà de ça il y a aussi mais ça
c'est c'est Erwan qui peut le dire aussi
au delà ça je crois qu'il y a cette
colère c'est détestation même hein du du
du du président de la République qui
n'est pas un phénomène nouveau on a vu
cette détestation contre Nicolas Sarkozy
on l'a vu contre François Hollande mais
elle
[Musique]
se manifeste avec des pics et la tête du
président de la République la tête de la
première ministre de dans la rue quoi
c'est absolument incroyable oui alors
déjà ce qu'on observe c'est que le
souhait de poursuite du mouvement des
manifestations et des blocages restent
très élevés 67 % de mesurer avec nos
partenaires du Figaro la semaine
dernière c'était même plus 6 points
après l'interview d'Emmanuel Macron qui
paradoxalement n'avait pas vraiment
désactivé la colère est concernant
renforcer la colère
poursuite du mouvement qui a pas fait
dégonfler ce souhait que le mouvement
s'arrête on le on l'avait vu avec les
gilets jaunes le souhait que le
mouvement s'arrête avait progressé après
la locution d'Emmanuel Macron on voit
qu'aujourd'hui cette cette intervention
n'a rien désactivé et concernant les
violences c'est assez particulier parce
qu'on a si Français sur 10 qui nous
disent c'est inacceptable c'est
injustifiable qui condamne les violences
mais pour autant on a une part
importante de la population qui nous dit
mais c'est logique et c'est de la faute
du gouvernement parce que son attitude a
été injuste et aussi et ça c'est
pourtant c'est le seul moyen de se faire
entendre parce que le mouvement
pacifique n'a pas été entendu donc une
espèce de tolérance de ces débordements
qui reste quand même un peu important
dans la population va voir comment ça va
se passer
l'opinion contre ces mobilisations et
contre cette réforme dans la mesure où
elle est entendue comme le seul moyen de
se faire entendre et de faire reculer le
gouvernement et c'est tout l'enjeu de
cette séquence c'est que l'invisibilité
du mouvement social dans les premiers
temps par le gouvernement a donné ce
sentiment qu'il faut contester et
contester fort pour se faire entendre ça
reste élevé après l'ampleur des
débordements la présence peut-être plus
nombreuse des Black Blocs dans les dans
les cortèges te faire reculer ce
sentiment mais c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
non seulement le souhait que les
manifestations perdurent est élevés mais
en plus les manifestations qui sont
devenus anti Macron et anti-machronie
plus largement que de contestations de
la réforme de retraite on va retourner à
Saint-Étienne retrouver Anthony
verpillon je le rappelle Anthony
journaliste à TL7 la télévision locale
de la Loire Anthony vous nous en parliez
est-ce qu'il faut s'attendre à des
fortes mobilisations aujourd'hui du côté
Saint-Étienne
d'anticiper mais en tout cas comme je
vous le disais depuis l'adoption en 49-3
ça s'est renforcé dans les rues la
dernière manifestation c'était jeudi et
il y avait entre alors c'est toujours la
bataille des chiffres mais entre 6000
personnes selon la police et je crois de
mémoire c'était 50 000 selon les
syndicats alors évidemment ils font
trouver un juste milieu entre entre ces
deux chiffres là mais ça s'est renforcé
et puis la colère est vraiment ciblée
sur les tournages principaux je dirais
de qui représente cette réforme Emmanuel
Macron et Elizabeth borne alors on n'est
pas encore au pied qu'avec la tête du
des présidents ou du moins à l'effigie
du président ou de la première ministre
à Saint-Étienne mais en tout cas il y a
des violences aussi on en a été victime
nous-mêmes en tant que journaliste très
directement voilà il y a un contexte
plus que tendu à Saint-Étienne comme
ailleurs en France de toute façon
rapidement Anthony est-ce qu'il y a
d'autres modes d'action programmés que
cette mobilisation dans la rue alors il
y en a déjà dès ce matin deux modes
d'action
[Musique]
pour rappel peut-être que de Paris on ne
prend pas la mesure mais en tout cas
cette ligne nuance Saint-Étienne c'est
la deuxième la plus utilisée de France
donc c'est très important le train était
bloqué normalement la reprise du trafic
c'était aux alentours de 8h30 et puis un
lycée également qui subit un blocage
dans le centre-ville de Saint-Etienne ce
matin et puis toute la semaine dernière
chaque jour avait son institution
bloquée il y a eu la poste il y a eu
enedis il y avait eu une des plus
grandes
plateforme logistique de la Loire et
c'était chaque jour voilà c'était
répétitif tous les matins on arrivait à
la rédaction en disant en se disant et
ben on va à droite ou à gauche pour
aller voir là où ça a bloqué donc voilà
les opposants en tout cas à la réforme
ne relâchent absolument pas merci
beaucoup Anthony verpillon d'avoir été
avec nous pour nous donner la
température du côté de Saint-Étienne
Antony journaliste à TL7 et donc ce
contexte on va découvrir le baromètre
doxa bah honnête mensuel pour public
Senna et la presse
Alex un mot sur les chiffres avec vous
premier enseignement la côte de
popularité d'Emmanuel Macron est en
baisse oui 30% des Français pensent
qu'Emmanuel Macron est un bon Président
de la République c'est une baisse de 6
points par rapport au mois dernier alors
globalement la popularité du président
et en baisse mais elle reste quand même
assez haute dans son propre camp 89 %
d'opinion favorables chez les
sympathisants Renaissance et elle est en
forte hausse et à noter chez les
sympathisants les républicains plus 12
points en un mois baisse de popularité
générale également pour la première
ministre Elisabeth borne 28% des
Français pensent qu'elle est une bonne
première ministre c'est un point de moi
que l'an dernier
Erwan à quoi c'est lié précisément cette
chute de popularité d'Emmanuel Macron
est-ce que c'est lié à la réforme en
elle-même est-ce que c'est lié à
l'utilisation du 49.3 est-ce que c'est
lié à la fermeté du chef de l'État
malgré le rejet de la réforme par les
Français c'est un peu des deux c'est
vrai que cette réforme des retraites qui
devait être un marqueur du second
quinquennat d'Emmanuel Macron a tout du
rendez-vous manqué avec les Français sur
le fond on a vu le rejet massif des
Français d'un texte qu'ils ont jugé
injuste socialement qui a provoqué une
grande colère mais sur la forme il y a
aussi cette adoption à travers le 49.3
qui qui a posé le sentiment d'un passage
en force démocratique donc entre colère
sociale et frustration démocratique les
Français ont des jugements nettement
moins favorables sur Emmanuel Macron ce
mois-ci est-ce qui est intéressant c'est
que par exemple on voit qui perd 10
points chez les 25 34 ans alors ça ça
peut être dû au passage en force
démocratique mais il perd aussi 10
points chez 50 64 ans ça ça peut être dû
à l'adoption forceps de la réforme des
retraites donc il y a ces deux points et
le la colère démocratique et la colère
sociale qui qui joue dans la tempête de
l'opinion et qui le place à un niveau
très bas de popularité on est juste
trois points au dessus sont plus bas
niveau depuis son élection en 2017
c'était 27% au moment des gilets jaunes
c'est un niveau très bas et on voit que
le lien des Français avec Emmanuel
Macron c'est fortement détérioré dans la
séquence c'était le risque il s'est
concrétisé et c'est vrai que ça pose
aussi la question du souffle qui va lui
rester pour la fin de son second mandat
le lien est rompu aujourd'hui entrée
manuel Macron et les français pour vous
oui c'est assez étonnant d'ailleurs
enfin c'est assez étonnant c'est curieux
de le constater alors que on est à peine
un an après sa réélection qui est une
réélection
assez triomphale quand même on peut le
dire et ça donne du je dirais quelques
motifs de satisfaction à tous ceux qui
disent que il a pas été réélu sur un
programme sur sa gouvernance sur sa
façon d'être mais en contre au contraire
Marine Le Pen évidemment
non ce qu'il y a c'est que ce qui est
terrible c'est que en plus sa campagne
électorale le seul sujet qui qui a
alimenté sa campagne et ses sujets de la
réforme des retraites c'était le seul
point la seule mesure concrète qui
figurait dans son dans son programme
donc voilà c'est aussi le paradoxe
français ça il a pas pris les Français
en traître finalement il a même présenté
un texte qui est largement à moindri par
rapport à au texte qui voulait faire
passer à l'époque donc c'est c'est tout
à fait ce qui veut dire quand même que
le mécontentement va bien au-delà de
cette réforme bien traite qu'il faut
mettre aussi la dedans probablement du
pouvoir d'achat ce qui est assez
d'ailleurs aussi paradoxal quand on sait
tous l'argent public qui a été dépensé
en France pour essayer d'amortir
justement l'inflation voilà on est on
est dans les contradictions françaises
plus général au-delà de la réforme des
retraites est-ce que c'est aussi un
rejet de la personne d'Emmanuel Macron
il y a ce problème il y a vraiment ce
sentiment oui que le les luttes ont
convergé en quelque sorte entre ces
inquiétudes sur le pouvoir d'achat qui
rendent l'avenir incertain on a vu aussi
les enjeux climatiques prendre leur
place dans les cortèges hein contre la
réforme des retraites donc il y a ce
mélange des choses et puis Emmanuel
Macron là où ça dessert son image c'est
que ça vient confirmer son étiquette de
président du des riches qui a du mal à
comprendre les préoccupations du
quotidien des Français donc c'est un
élément de preuve par rapport à tous les
stéréotypes négatif qui avait autour du
président et effectivement ça vient
renforcer le sentiment qu'il y a une
distance très forte entre ce qui propose
et ce que les Français attendent et vous
avez aussi étudié selon la proximité
partisane Alex donnait les chiffres
alors évidemment Emmanuel Macron a une
chute de popularité énorme chez les
sympathisants de gauche mais il prend 12
points de popularité chez les
républicains quelle lecture vous en
faites oui et puis on est dans une
droitisation de son image qui ne résonne
plus au sein de la gauche puis aussi ce
cette préférence pour l'ordre et la le
maintien du statu quo qui qui crée du
crédit dans l'électorat de droite après
ça reste léger c'est une augmentation de
12 points et il est à 51% je crois donc
ça reste encore léger mais c'est vrai
que il y a ce point de conservation des
des acquis qui séduit le lectorat à
droite effectivement ils sont l'image se
droitise un peu et évidemment par
contraste aussi avec une espèce de
désordre qui règne chez les républicains
il y a pas une figure qui se dégage pour
justement avoir une parole forte et donc
finalement la parole forte d'une
certaine façon c'est Emmanuel
donne plus raison à la ligne ceamarlex
qu'à la ligne Pradier
il a commencé à soutenir la réforme du
crédit mais il reste par contre
nettement plus populaire que pralier au
sein des sympathisants les républicains
non plus hein il y a peut-être Kemer
j'en ai rien dit c'est simple
elle chute beaucoup moins qui est manuel
Macron elle perd un point mais elle
reste basse ça veut dire quoi qu'elle
qu'elle est moins pour les Français et
les moins identifié à cette réforme que
c'est moins sa responsabilité alors en
fait elle avait déjà perdu ses points le
mois précédent Emmanuel Macron lui c'est
un rattrapage c'est qu'il est dans une
séquence réforme des institutions
internationales donc c'est ils se sont
retour sur le terrain de la réforme des
retraites qui a entraîné se rattrapage
d'un popularité ça c'est le poids pour
Elisabeth borne elle est à 28% de
popularité après moins d'un an à
Matignon c'est un très bas niveau il est
prédécesseurs qui ont eu ces niveaux là
et c'est pas forcément bon signe c'est
Manuel Valls 24% pendant la loi travail
et Dominique de Villepin 26% pour le
conflit sur le CPE puis un autre point
pour Elizabeth borne et qui est plus
problématique pour pour la suite pour
elle c'est que son image était
relativement peu construite dans
l'esprit des français quand elle est
arrivée à Matignon et finalement son
image s'est construite dans cette
séquence très négative pour l'exécutif
donc ça va être difficile peut-être pour
elle de décoller des étiquettes
d'autorité et de verticalité de son
image pour la suite
elisabethornell est fragile
très très populaire de toute manière et
puis elle a une image qu'elle a du mal
si vous voulez à faire évoluer elle a
une image de technicienne
technocrates extrêmement quasi sévère
enfin un petit peu
je dirais qu'elle a un profil qui est
pas très empathique non plus et on voit
qu'elle a du mal à le faire évoluer et
je pense que l'image qu'elle a dans la
population toute manière c'est une image
de de
technicienne qui vient à appliquer une
une mesure qui a été imposée par le
Président de la République le rapport
entre le Premier ministre et la
population n'est pas très important
finalement je pense pas qu'il y a une
détestation de Madame borne comme il
peut y avoir une détestation d'Emmanuel
Macron
je dirais comme collaboratrice d'une
certaine façon malheureusement c'est
c'est le terme surtout dans une période
de quinquennat du président de la
République
Erwan dans ce baromètre vous mesurez
aussi le palmarès d'adhésion des
personnalités politiques alors comme
tous les mois c'est Édouard Philippe qui
reste en tête mais il perd 7 points de
popularité il patie d'appartenir à la
majorité oui tout à fait ce qu'on
observe c'est alors déjà le désaveu pour
la classe politique et généralisé quel
que soit les tendances politiques on
voit une baisse des codes d'adhésion des
personnalités ce sont aussi c'est
vraiment la fracture liée aux 49-3 ou au
débat au lieu qu'il y avait eu à
l'Assemblée nationale aussi
préalablement mais en tout cas
l'ensemble de la classe politique est
desservie par cette séquence mais ceux
qui en pâtissent le plus fortement c'est
les sympathiser les figures de la
majorité et ses alliés et Édouard
Philippe perd 7 points de code
d'adhésion ce mois-ci il passe à 34% et
à 41% encore le mois dernier donc il
recule très fortement il se situe plus à
deux points de Marine Le Pen et c'est ça
l'enjeu du moment c'est que les
oppositions ne progressent pas en
crédibilité mais leur écart de
crédibilité avec la majorité a tendance
à se réduire et c'est là où il y a un
peut-être un point de vigilance aussi
pour l'exécutif numéro 2 Marine Le Pen
numéro 3 Jordan dardella est-ce que le
rassemblement national tire un bénéfice
de cette séquence là je crois qu'il y a
une projection qui a été faite par un
autre institut de sondage en cas de
dissolution de l'Assemblée et on a vu
que le parti qui en profitait le plus
c'était le rassemblement national ce qui
est ce qui est aussi indéparadocs parce
que le rassemblement national par
définition
ou plutôt pas par définition mais ne dis
rien sur cette réforme de proposer rien
pas d'alternative et c'est lui qui tire
les marrons du feu donc c'est aussi mais
bon c'est pas très étonnant non plus
qu'ils soient le vainqueur entre
guillemets parce qu'il faudrait que tout
ça soit confirmé en cas de en cas de
dissolution vous ne mesurez vous aussi
est-ce qu'un sentiment chez les Français
que le rassemblement national et bien
tire profit de cette séquence justement
je pense que on y est pas encore
justement je pense que le rassemblement
national on va dire que c'est peut-être
ceux qui pâtissent le moins de la
situation mais vu que les autres
baissent ils se rapprochent de cette
population et c'est ça qui est
intéressant ici on regarde par contre
d'autres indicateurs et la proximité des
préoccupations aux Français il y a
quasiment un Français sur deux qui
jugent que Marine Le Pen comprend les
préoccupations des Français là où ils
sont seulement 3 sur 10 pour Emmanuel
Macron donc c'est peut-être cette écart
là et finalement dans un dans un cas où
on considère que le gouvernement est
très maltraitance socialement pour pour
les Français ça fait le jeu du
rassemblement national mais peut-être
dans un deuxième temps aujourd'hui il se
maintiennent et ils patissent un peu
moins de la séquence et Erwan vous avez
posé la question française de la
capacité d'Emmanuel Macron a réformer
qu'en pensent les Français à Alex et
bien cette capacité du président réformé
elle n'est pas remise en cause dans
l'opinion puisque 50% des personnes
interrogées pense qu'Emmanuel Macron
arrivera au final à mener les réformes
on est dans un 55 ans oui alors et après
ce samedi rien de ce que les Français
pensent de la méthode Macron pour mener
des réformes parce que en réalité si
c'est maintenir des réformes assez
verticales qui passent avec des
ordonnances avec le 49-3 avec le PLFSS
le c'est de toute façon une méthode qui
ne convient pas aux Français ça ne dit
rien du rejet de la méthode ça ne dit
rien du rejet qui pourrait y avoir si
des réformes posées problèmes dans
l'opinion mais il y a le sentiment quand
même pour un Français sur deux moins
d'un an après l'élection d'Emmanuel
Macron qui ne parviendra pas à mener les
référents qu'ils soient donc il y a ce
sentiment quand même d'impasse du
pouvoir qui existe dans la population ça
rend la suite du quinquennat difficile
cette réponse
la suite du quinquennat difficile on
savait que cette réforme des retraites
sera un marqueur et que si jamais et
bien elle pénètre à passer et on n'est
pas encore au bout du feuilleton et bien
ça compliquerait sérieusement son son
quinquennat simplement il y a des choses
qui sont aussi intéressantes regardez le
le
lundi dernier la loi sur la relance
nucléaire et passer parce que ils ont
réussi à trouver un consensus avec les
républicains et avec les communistes
donc ils peuvent peut-être sur certains
sujets
arriver qu'est-ce qu'elle a dit au Grand
Jury Le Figaro il y a fait passer plus
de 20 ans
il y en a trois qui sont passés
je dirais très symbolique comme celui
d'Air très ou il suffirait aussi d'une
réforme je sais pas dans l'éducation
nationale ou des réformes vraiment qui
sont des réformes
totemiques et ben celle là c'est
peut-être les plus difficiles
effectivement parce que c'est là où les
confrontations se douent alors
effectivement la majorité présidentielle
se targue d'avoir fait adopter au
Parlement plus de 20 textes on peut
quand même préciser qu'il y a aussi des
textes qui sont des textes de procédure
administratives qui ne sont pas très
politiques et puis il y a eu des textes
importants comme le pouvoir d'achat ou
là c'est difficile de ne pas créer une
majorité autour de ce sujet il y a eu
également le texte pour renforcer les
moyens de la police donc là il y avait
une certaine aisance à trouver une
majorité de ces textes on peut quand
même se demander s'il y a pas un doute
au sein de l'exécutif sur cette capacité
à réformer car ce qu'on retient quand
même de l'interview d'Emmanuel Macron
c'est qu'il ne souhaite plus trop
réformé avec le Parlement il dit on va
faire moins de loi on va passer par du
règlement par du décret faire des lois
plus courtes saucissonner les lois pour
essayer de trouver une majorité à gauche
une majorité à droite donc on voit bien
qu'Emmanuel Macron croit de moins en
moins dans une capacité à réformer avec
le Parlement ça va être dur oui ça va
être ça va être dur et bien sûr que ça
va être dur ça va être un travail de
tous les instants mais je pense que
quand il y a pas de majorité absolue
c'est un travail de tous les instants
moi
je me souviens de la période Rocard qui
est une période plus facile parce que le
49-3 vous pouviez y recourir comme vous
voulez que vous vouliez et il y avait un
conseiller à Matignon qui s'appelait Guy
Carcassonne qui était un très grand
juriste et qui arrivait
à trouver des compromis autour de textes
qui étaient des textes pas simples
sachez par exemple que la contribution
sociale généralisée la CSG elle a été
adoptée par 49-3
5 voies d'écart d'ailleurs enfin 5 fois
d'écart
là
cinq voies d'écart bon ce qui vous
prouve que on n'est pas dans un contexte
tout à fait inédit un mot Erwan puisque
Elizabeth borne a aussi dit qu'elle
n'utiliserait plus le 49-3 hors-tex
budgétaire tout ça ça peut être une
réponse attendue par les français ou pas
sur la sur la méthode oui après il
aurait peut-être fallu en parler à
priori plutôt qu'à posteriori parce que
là on est dans la pré-cou et c'est les
Français sont quand même très attaché à
ce qui s'est passé il y a 15 jours
plutôt qu'aujourd'hui mais pour Emmanuel
Macron c'est il y a quand même un enjeu
c'est de réendosser son avis de
réformateur dynamique c'était un des
fondements de son image positive auprès
de son socle électoral et c'est vrai que
cette cette image de réformateur elle
est fortement abîmée et ce qui passait
pour une volonté de décloisonner la
France de rendre la France plus
compétitive en 2017 c'est vu aujourd'hui
comme de l'autorité de la verticalité et
des décisions qui sont prises vraiment
quasi tout seul ou en petit comité c'est
ça c'est ça peut-être c'est là dessus
dans la méthode qui a des choses à faire
évoluer je pense on va voir la suite de
votre sondage
Erwan avec les solutions la réponse à
apporter à cette crise pour les Français
bien la première réponse tient en un mot
Oriane la dissolution dissolution de
l'Assemblée nationale on renvoie les
citoyens aux urnes et on voit ce qui se
passe et bien 61% des Français ils sont
favorables 38% sont contre 1% ne se
prononce pas et puis l'autre réponse à
apporter selon les Français c'est le
référendum avec le fameux riple
référendum d'initiative partagée qui est
lancé actuellement par les
parlementaires de gauche alors pour
lancer par les parlementaires de gauche
pour annuler le report de l'âge de
départ à la retraite alors on précise il
y a plusieurs étapes à franchir avant de
pouvoir organiser ce référendum sur les
retraites première étape il faut qu'au
moins 185 parlementaires signent une
proposition loi en faveur de ce
référendum alors ça c'est fait les
signatures sont là le Conseil
constitutionnel constitutionnel est en
train d'examiner le texte deuxième étape
plus difficile ce référendum doit être
soutenu par 4,9 millions de signatures
citoyennes les parlementaires de gauche
auront 9 mois pour recueillir ces
signatures et si ces signatures sont au
rendez-vous et bien le président de la
République aura alors 6 mois pour
organiser ce référendum sauf si le
Parlement examine cette proposition de
loi en faveur du Rip et là ça mettrait
un terme à la procédure alors en tout
cas ce que dit le baromètre doxa c'est
que les Français sont favorables à ce
référendum d'initiative partagée 71%
espère qu'il va avoir lieu s'il y a si
il a lieu 75% y participeront et 67%
voteront pour l'annulation du report de
l'âge de départ à la retraite
dissolution est RIP ce sont les deux
solutions prenées par les Français dans
votre sondage Erwan voilà en tout cas on
voit que majoritairement les Français ne
veulent pas de statu quo ils veulent
qu'ils se passe quelque chose pour
mettre fin à cette situation d'impasse
61% favorable à la dissolution pour deux
raisons parce qu'il y a des forces
politiques qui voient leur intérêts qui
pourraient voir leur groupe
parlementaire progressé et prendre de
l'ampleur mais aussi parce que dans
l'opinion il y a une mauvaise image de
la législature actuelle les débats à
l'Assemblée sur les retraites ont laissé
le sentiment de député qui se comporte
pas comme il devrait donc il y a ce il y
a une un regard négatif sur la
législature actuelle et aussi le
l'éventualité de faire grossir son son
groupe parlementaire sur le référendum
c'est intéressant parce que ça montre
que finalement il y a un gros enjeu de
légitimité on l'a vu d'ailleurs au début
des prises de parole d'Emmanuel Macron
sur le texte c'est de dire la réforme
est légitime parce que j'ai été élu et
ayant été élu mon programme est légitimé
et il y a ce sentiment des Français qui
veut dire ce qui est légitime c'est
défendre nos doléances donc finalement
cet outil de légitimation et de
démocratie directe ça recueille un
intérêt très important dans la
population on voit d'ailleurs que les
gens qui voteraient votre être très
majoritairement en faveur de
l'annulation du report de l'âge de
départ après pour ces outils là pour
qu'ils soient puissants finalement parce
que si on votait pour l'annulation de du
report de légal de départ on repartir à
zéro là où un référendum pourrait être
intéressant c'est s'il faisait choisir
aux Français des options entre
l'augmentation des cotisations entre
l'allongement de la durée de travail si
finalement il y avait un grand moment de
débat national en amont de ce référendum
pour choisir des options et là l'outil
de démocratie directe serait puissant il
viendrait peut-être compléter la
démocratie représentative qui est très
critiquée parce qu'il y a peu de
démocratie qui est donnée aux Français
aujourd'hui entre les deux les élections
présidentielles ça peut être la sortie
non je pense que c'est la sortie pour le
président de la République s'il fait ou
là ou l'autre
il est évidemment renvoyé renvoyé si je
faisais sortie de route pour lui parce
que vous savez très bien qu'en France on
ne répond pas à la question du
référendum mais à celui qui la pose
et là plus que jamais de contenu de ce
qu'on vient de dire précédemment
le référendum moi c'est pas un outil que
je trouve extrêmement
utile dans une démocratie parce que je
pense que c'est la dérive a beaucoup de
démagogie et ça enflamme le pays de
façon tout à fait inutile et puis pour
ce qui est de la dissolution bah la
dissolution il est sûr qu'il se fait à
acquérir puisque la dissolution les
sondages le montrent ça réduit ça
réduira la majorité du président de la
République quitte d'ailleurs à la faire
disparaître mais c'est ça qui est
intéressant dans une dissolution c'est
qu'on voit pas très bien l'alternat
parce que même si le rassemblement
national
bien connaît une poussée et ce qui sera
en mesure d'avoir une majorité je pense
que les majorités sont introuvrables
pour les uns et pour les autres et donc
la dissolution serait extrêmement
dangereuse et fragiliserait d'une
certaine façon encore un peu plus le
paysage politique que que nous avons
donc là où l'autre des outils nous
emmènerait à mon avis alors qu'on est
dans une période qui s'annonce difficile
sur le plan économique avec une
instabilité
financière qui me paraît
à redouter avec un chômage qui s'annonce
parce que je sais pas si vous avez vu
mais il y a des très mauvaises nouvelles
de ce point de vue à l'horizon si en
plus on est dans une instabilité
politique et bien la France va au devant
de jour difficile
Erwan qu'Emmanuel Macron il est un peu
coincé sur cette sortie de crise oui
aujourd'hui le tout l'enjeu c'est de
savoir s'il faut mettre la réforme sur
pause comme l'appel la CFDT s'il faut
rediscuter de certains paramètres mais
il y a quand même quelque chose qui est
assez évident et dès les sondages qu'on
faisait pendant la campagne
présidentielle c'est que les Français ne
veulent pas d'un report de l'âge légal à
la retraite de départ à la retraite donc
il y a ce sentiment que finalement sans
enlever là je légale de départ il ne se
passera rien donc c'est entre la
capacité d'imposer sa réforme et
d'imposer sa réforme combien même elle
le rendrait impopulaire parce que c'est
nécessaire pour les finances publiques
et la nécessité de contenter les
Français qui Emmanuel Macron va devoir
faire des choix et des concessions à
minima très rapidement pour finir
Laurent Berger ce matin appelle à une
médiation pour trouver une voie de
sortie est-ce que ça peut être la voix
de sortie oui il faut voir mais il faut
d'abord attendre la décision du Conseil
constitutionnel me semble-t-il faut que
toutes les formalités soient remplies et
puis après une médiation mais quel type
de médiation si c'est Laurent Berger qui
met de la médiation on sait où ça va
c'est à dire que c'est le retrait de la
réforme parce que moi je suis très
intéressé par le discours de Laurent
Berger qui est devenu le deus
qu'il est élu par personne sauf par les
adhérents de la CFDT et qu'il représente
que quelques 800 000 Français bon il
faut arrêter aussi le président de la
République a été élu au suffrage
universel direct l'Assemblée nationale a
été élu au suffrage universel direct
donc s'il vous plaît gardons raison il
veut nommer un ou deux médiateurs pour
sortir de la cuisine ouverte
ils vont continuer à parler de cette
réforme des retrait de challenge de la
presse régionale
[Musique]
de la presse régionale cette dixième
journée de mobilisation et oui colère
Force 10 à la Une du journal Sud-Ouest
aujourd'hui en 10e acte sous haute
tension elle a une de l'Est éclair un
mardi à haut risque titre le journal La
Dépêche du Midi alors que les autorités
redoutent de nouvelles violences en
marge des cortèges de manifestants pour
faire face au Black Blocs le ministère
de l'Intérieur a prévu un dispositif de
sécurité dit inédit 13000 policiers
gendarmes sont mobilisés dans tout le
pays un enjeu sécuritaire important
notamment dans certaines villes après
les débordements de jeudi c'est le cas à
Lyon c'est à la une du Progrès de Lyon
c'est le cas aussi à Nantes n'entre
doute le pire à la Une de Presse Océan
et notamment les commerçants nantais une
nouvelle journée de grève et de
lassitude qui commence à gagner les
usagers du service public c'est à la Une
du journal L'Union école fermée train
supprimer commerce ralenti la
désorganisation du pays commence à peser
sur les Français même sur ceux qui
soutiennent le mouvement contre la
réforme des retraites Juliette une mère
de trois enfants habitante de Reims elle
explique dans les colonnes de l'Union je
la cite tous les parents sa gérer une
journée la chance d'un professeur une
journée de grève mais le plus le plus
éprouvant dans cette situation c'est que
ça fait deux mois que ça dure alors oui
les grèves durs mais il n'y a pas
vraiment de grève générale la France
n'est pas à l'arrêt et le journal Paris
Normandie et c'est d'expliquer pourquoi
c'est grève générale ne prennent pas
pour Stéphane Sirault et bien
spécialiste des conflits sociaux l'une
des raisons et que les syndicats ne sont
pas implantés dans tous les secteurs de
l'économie dans toutes les entreprises
et puis le blocage total du pays
contrairement à certaines déclarations
de responsables syndicaux et bien ce
n'est pas forcément dans l'intérêt d'une
union inter syndicale qui ne veut pas se
mettre l'opinion à dos et Alex pour
l'instant Emmanuel Macron ne parvient
pas à calmer la colère contre sa réforme
des retraites mais oui le pari
d'Emmanuel Macron à l'épreuve de la rue
s'est allé une du Dauphiné Libéré
aujourd'hui le président de la
République qui veut jouer la pèsement
avec les syndicats mais qui reste
inflexibles sur sa réforme un président
dans l'impasse estime le journal La
Provence Emmanuel Macron qui a demandé à
sa première ministre et bien d'élargir
une majorité présidentielle qui s'est
montrée trop faible pour voter cette
réforme des retraites les oppositions
n'ont pas l'intention de bouger aucune
porte de sortie de crise pour l'instant
ne se dessine pour Emmanuel Macron merci
Alex et c'est la Une du Figaro et mais
Elisabeth borne en quête d'une majorité
introuvable
dans le Figaro merci beaucoup merci au
revoir de l'ESTRO on rappelle votre
sondage au dos que ça apporte une
excellent et la presse régionale sur la
capacité d'Emmanuel Macron à réformer sa
cote de popularité bref l'après réforme
des retraites merci beaucoup Erwan
d'être venue nous le présenter merci à
tous on se retrouve demain et
[Musique]